andrés bienvenido france24
de donde surgió esta idea de que los
excombatientes se dediquen a este
proyecto
bueno muy buenas noches esta idea surgió
a partir de un hecho concreto que fue el
tema de la pandemia donde los municipios
donde nosotros estamos avanzando en
nuestro proceso de reincorporación se
vieron confinados y los proyectos
productivos que estaban dedicados a la
confección pues sufrieron estos efectos
nosotros a partir de eso comenzamos un
proceso de articulación de varios
talleres de firmantes del acuerdo para
gestionar en ese entonces tela para
tapabocas para no tener que cerrar
nuestros talleres y también para
contribuir a la lucha contra la pandemia
a partir de eso comenzamos un proceso de
articulación hoy somos 31 talleres que
conformamos la red nacional de
confecciones por la paz y nos
encontramos en 16 departamentos de
colombia las zonas más afectadas por el
conflicto armado bueno y cómo funcionan
estos talleres y aproximadamente cuántas
personas hacen parte del proyecto
bueno nosotros
somos alrededor de 220 ex combatientes
firmantes del acuerdo de paz como lo
dije ahorita que pertenecemos a 31
proyectos productivos de confecciones
trabajamos en las zonas más pegadas por
el conflicto no solamente con firmantes
sino también con víctimas del conflicto
armado
con organizaciones campesinas y sociales
calculamos que estamos beneficiando
indirectamente alrededor de 1200
personas en toda colombia en estos
territorios estamos dedicados a la
confección sobre todo en cinco líneas en
la línea de calzado en la línea de moda
y en la línea casual deportiva y
accesorios a partir de nuestro oficio en
la confección después estamos haciendo
digamos realidad el enfoque reparador
del acuerdo de paz en los territorios
pero también el enfoque comunitario
porque como lo mencioné no solamente
trabajamos firmantes del acuerdo de paz
sino que trabajamos con las comunidades
donde desarrollamos nuestros procesos de
reincorporación andrés precisamente a
eso aparecen temas muy distantes pero
como es que la moda puede llegar a ser
un escenario para construir paz
bueno la moda puede ser un escenario
para construir paz porque nosotros por
un lado estamos construyendo una digamos
una nueva economía los territorios a
partir de proyectos productivos
solidarios en alianza con los campesinos
en zonas lo que han que han sufrido
mucho las consecuencias del conflicto de
conflicto armado desde ese punto de
vista la moda está siendo un elemento
reparador está siendo un elemento para
la implementación de los acuerdos está
haciendo un elemento para avanzar en
nuestra reincorporación socioeconómica y
desde ese punto de vista se está
haciendo pues un elemento político para
la constru para la contribución de la
paz en colombia
ahora como ha sido la acogida de su
cliente sus clientes como valoran su
trabajo
ha sido grande ha sido grandiosa porque
la gente valora mucho que nosotros
hayamos llegado a digamos hasta este
momento a pesar de las grandes
dificultades que hemos sufrido nosotros
tenemos
337 de firmantes del 'acuerdo asesinados
tenemos un incumplimiento por parte del
estado en muchos de los puntos que
tienen que ver con la reincorporación
socioeconómica y aún así con la voluntad
de los excombatientes y con el apoyo de
la sociedad civil y de la comunidad
internacional hemos logrado pues llegar
hasta este punto llegar a colombia vamos
a llegar al evento más importante de la
moda en colombia y uno de los más
importantes en latinoamérica y ahí
estamos demostrando nuestra voluntad de
paz y nuestra voluntad con la
implementación del acuerdo en andrés
zuluaga coordinador de la red nacional
de confesiones por la paz renace gracias
por acompañarnos aquí en france 24
muchas gracias a ustedes